I have so many girls being like Oh my
God like I see how much money you're
making should I start an only fans and
I'm like you're ugly with a face like
that
[Music]
so we were just talking about Miss
Pamela Anderson I'm so sorry
reparations are too hey no one can
cancel me if I'm taking accountability
and apologizing that's true that's true
yeah this is a new video so they don't
understand a contest watch the last one
watch the last video you gotta look for
it
comes out after this one that's why you
gotta watch all the videos to understand
yeah it's like why is she apologizing to
Pam Anderson yeah my bad girly you're
hot I really like you we're all fans all
right so um there was apparently uh this
moment in history when Tim Allen flashed
Pamela Anderson yo I heard about that
that [__] it was true what and then
recently uh well he is kind of a
gangster he's been locked up and [__]
Tim Allen denied that he's a drug he
used to be a drug Smuggler I love that
[__] my friend just got out of jail for
that
smuggling yeah I'm all about I love
especially mushrooms like I just think
drugs should be legalized all all drugs
um I'd say if drugs were legalized
people would not be overdosing off of
fentanyl so I do think all drugs should
be at least decriminalized so you could
be getting it from pharmacies or
something so like there's no fentanyl in
it people wouldn't be dying the way uh
well yeah that's well yeah the fentanyl
kind of [__] everything up yep yeah
kind of well so this is the story of uh
what happened when Tim apparently
flashed her so did he go
[Laughter]
because that would be pretty [__]
time and Wilson went like this
so the pair working together on the 90s
sitcom Home Improvement uh and in her
new Memoir love Pamela she alleged that
the show's star Alan had flashed her in
1991 when he was 37 and when she was age
23. he denied it uh which was no
surprise to her apparently but in this
new interview she basically talks about
how he has to deny it because look at
the Times we're in if he said oh yeah I
did that he'd be I mean a lot of these
stories are just the tip of the iceberg
what's the context though okay I know
the context I've watched okay so
basically uh he flashed her his dick and
was like I've seen you naked now you've
seen me naked we're even and then ran
out of the room he ran out of the muscle
sounds like a comedian bit like he is
yeah not to get his back or anything I'm
just like trying to understand it's also
I know we know a lot of comedians that
go naked in front of yeah yeah yeah
girls and guys like Bobby Lee has been
making fun of me he's in the story
yeah same same
you too but also but everyone see Bobby
Lee's dick it also didn't know if it was
that I feel left out yeah I don't know
how big was [__] around you know I
just don't know the full concert she
says it was my first dance I've got a
lot of pubes that I was in my dressing
room first day of film and I came out
and then he came out of his dressing
room and he had his robot and he goes
Flash and you close it and he goes now
we're even I've seen you naked and
you've seen me naked now we can start
the show wow
it sounds like for sure a little
predatory a sure little weird like but
very 90s
you think um he was just like here's the
goods Maybe here's a chance I could
probably [__] I don't know man what a
weirdo yeah it's a weird Booth yeah
especially because like you think it
would was probably flaccid well let's
hope so yeah and I wonder if he's a
grower or a shower it's so hard I think
to really know unless you're there
because I've also like you know in
Hollywood they construct [__] to make
magic you know what I mean so it's like
they like like for example
um I've heard of directors that will
straight up like go up to and just slap
you and then action and then right after
boom that is exactly the scene I needed
to get magic hat because I know in
Hollywood there's a lot of like just
weird cultural [__] like that yeah but
this is like Home Improvement I know but
still let's go though but that's the
take I needed it's like and now you've
seen my tools but I don't but then maybe
that is I don't know that's the report
that made that a hit show I don't know
I'm not doesn't mean it's right it's
just people no I get what you're saying
because if people found out our chat
groups and everything and what happens
in a writer's room then it's just not
Corporate America It's Entertainment and
the rules are different yeah and
Hollywood just has like crazy like
eccentric [__] that like like Diddy has
to have a bowl of blue M Ms yeah in his
Green Room well then flashing a
co-worker though is still kind of weird
it is weird when you're 37 and she's 23
and she's obviously known for being like
super hot and did Playboy and stuff like
that and it's like but if it did this to
all his other casts like Jonathan Taylor
Thomas and all of the kids
Thomas
he shows the [__] boom mic guys
[Applause]
because what makes it not creepy about
Bobby is everyone's seen his dick yeah
because he does it to everybody yeah
yeah yeah that's his finishing can you
please check IDs first to make sure yo
I'm not flashing dude I know maybe maybe
I don't know that would be bad
this definitely sounds like a weird
Power Play Move I mean it does yeah it's
the [__] guy yeah at that time you
know and like I feel like when you're a
guy like that and the guy it's your show
and then you got this [__] she was
like the [__] chick at that time what
was his response he said no
no
it never happened I would never do such
a thing okay
okay like these girls No One's Gonna
believe these girls and now that like
people are believing these girls are
like [__] I did some [__] up and it
does prove it right that she didn't say
anything at the time because she
probably knew it wouldn't matter yeah
yeah her voice wouldn't really do
anything back then I mean look at what
happened with the sex tape everyone
thought that she released it herself and
she's like no it was stolen from my home
and no one took her seriously nobody
gave a [__] yeah with your big ass chin
talking to Pam about well it was cool
like ew you're gross oh dude yeah it's
such a weird time
I saw him in real life it's bigger than
[__] the the it's very defined
McDonald's Moon guy chin yeah
oh really this is so weird
and it was [__] massive when you see
your profile it's like he's like he
looks like a character it's so yeah yeah
it is it's pretty big yeah see Pam I got
your back because of this series though
I really like her yeah oh and she's like
seems like such a chill cool person yeah
I feel like she was beyond her years
because it's like in the 90s like early
2000s even afterwards of like a few
years ago girls were shamed so much and
now it's like it's kind of cool to be a
[__] I mean you still get [__] shamed a
lot but it's like not as bad at least
there's more upsides today at least
you're balling yeah you're bottling yeah
you guys are all poor
I wear
is the only thing that I've ever seen
where like uh you know other chicks like
or girls even if they're joking around
they'll joke around and still be like
damn should we start an only fans you
know what I mean yeah they'll just say
[__] like that even though they would
never do it yeah when they hear about
what only fan stars are making that kind
of makes me laugh though because they
make it sound like it's so easy like
they think like oh let me just take off
clothes and then I'll [__] get
followers and I'm like you really make
like 10 bucks dude you meet a lot of
girls that really think it's so easy I
have so many girls being like Oh my God
like I see how much money you're making
should I start and only fans and I'm
like you're ugly
with a face like that
[Laughter]
pudding you have to have like a
brandable personality like some of the
girls don't want to show their
personality they're like oh my God I got
one hate comment I'm like you know I get
hundreds of hate comments a day like
people call me fat ugly fatherless on
your of they do that I'm not on my own
no I was like Dad they pay to do that
[__] yeah yeah that's crazy I have had
some comments on my only fans like one
guy was like when it when you dropping
your next sex tape and I'm like I'm
celibate for men I'm not doing it till
like I actually [__] a man again which
will be a while and then he's like well
fine I'm not gonna uh like pay for a
girl who weighs uh double me anyways it
was something like that and I was like
[__] you so what is he like 90 pounds
he's 60 people was he in the third grade
he's all frail typing he's in a garbage
lady but a lot of these girls don't have
like the back not the background not not
the backbone but like they don't have
like the confidence to be like I'm gonna
get hate comments every day even from
your fans your fans will be like I
thought that you were gonna do more in
this video or I thought this or that or
like why can't you be more sexual why
are you so sexual it's like you're never
oh God yeah you're never gonna hit it
they're on only fans going why are you
so sexual
that was way too secular video
unfollowed no but like some fans get
pissed if like because I only have a sex
tape from like two different days with
the same guy but like my fans are like
why are you [__] someone okay I'm
sorry I thought that's what you because
you're cheating on them yeah because I'm
like cheating wow I thought you were
like other girls which what's the story
with the celibacy thing you've been
doing for how long and what store over a
year
um so I've gone on and off being
celibate um basically since rehab
choice but um my freshman year I raw
dogged a lot of Frat Boys got chlamydia
that was cool and then I was like you
know what it's curable yeah it's
terrible she goes really I've had it for
16 years
and then I discovered what a vibrator
was and then when I discovered what a
vibrator was I was celibate for like a
whole year it was it was over a year
until I started dating someone and then
it was ended up being like a really
toxic relationship and then afterwards I
had another hoe face because I'm like if
I don't [__] someone new I'm gonna [__]
him so then I had another holiday
because if you don't have something to
upgrade to you always go back to the
best come
[Music]